yeah welcome to this video yeah this
will be a short video that um that shows
two games that are recently played on
this some casual correspondence server
chessboard op net and it's um yeah it's
a rare occurrence that you get a game
did you play yourself and this is which
is almost identical to a game that has
been already played before um yeah I'll
show you this game both on game some I
with the same opening with the Evans
gambit and they also meant to show that
the Evans gambit is a very interesting
opening to study for white if you want
to sharpen up your opening repertoire I
want to add some interesting line to
your to your yeah - you're opening
choices then I think the evidence is
very very interesting let's let's get
going we've got the Italian game and now
before this the Evans gambit I think if
you look at E 4 E 5 double kinghorn
openings um there is really a bunch of
gambits around I think of yeah almost
all of this game but the Evans is them
maybe the most interesting want to play
usually white really has got some some
compensation and often black really
needs to return the pawn to get get an
equal game black of course has chances
to equalize it's not charitable for
black but it's a very good practical
weapon as black really needs to know
what he's doing and it's always
dangerous so I'm in this game here black
accepted the pawn which is also by far
the mainline black can also play this
this declined
version of the gambit but this has never
been so popular
um it's playable it's not not a bad move
but nothing that should should scare
white white can continue with various
smooth also a four here on Knight c3
alright so but he took it and then c3
winning a tempo on this Bishop which is
one key IDM tipped like blatem Bishop to
a5 yeah this is arguably the mainline
Black has got some alternatives of
course um one solid alternative here's
the new Bishop e7 which will also be
most likely be the move that Dan will
recommend in my 45 repertoire series and
I think this is relatively easy to play
for black compared to um to Bishop a5
but you also hear White's the last
interesting play ok lets you turn to to
the game whoever should be 5 was played
and now I just played D form realizing
the idea of this opening to establish
the center which black cam took on
default this is also a fine move and now
Queen b3 I think this move is as much
more exact them compared to castles
which is also impossible but after
castles there are simply other ideas
that like might have a disposal for
instance um it is sometimes an idea for
black now to play quickly Knight to e7
and d5 somehow that the castles move is
not the most direct one so I went could
be 3 him directly attacking of 7 yeah
which like really needs to care about he
cannot allow me to take on f7 here black
usually covers the spawn with the Queen
there's not much choice and in this game
you played Queen e7
just saying as some a very risky move
Queen f6 is the Sabaton booth and this
is said the move which I will show in
the second game I had identical moves up
to this point in those two games but in
the the second game the black player
played Queen f6 witches as mentioned
better but here Queen d7 was played the
problem with this Queen e7 movers that
it takes away the some potential square
for the g8 nod and did somehow in this
aspect doesn't help to get the King out
of the center all right white just
castles obviously I just want to get the
King out of this and yeah of course
black cannot not grab the born rookie
one just wins the Queen and black just
needs to make sure that his King gets
out of the center in a way it's some not
easy to do here now took another pawn on
c3 yeah this pawn wrap I think is just
too risky here black has a good
alternative and this is a yeah the
modern main line of this
in playing um Bishop to b6 after Bishop
e6 whiter takes on d4 Knight takes
Knight takes Bishop takes and nitrous e3
and I def 6 now yeah this is played to
this day
and it's um yeah probably the the way
that like most off plays against against
this opening it's still very risky um
black has grabbed two pawns
white has some numerous ways to attack
black Bishop a3 9595 yeah black really
walks a tightrope um it's playable for
black obviously it's um it's still
recommended in books but studying this
kind of line for white can be a very
rewarding as some black still needs to
be very careful it's um in the game he
didn't do that didn't play Bishop e6 but
as mentioned he grabbed the pawn on c3
and I think after this black is already
young I think it's almost very very
difficult let let's put it this way too
to hold this position why just
recaptures and now Knight f6 was played
I think in this position was the last
the last chance to really put up
something of a fight
I think black needs to to just grab this
Bishop at the grab this night with the
bishop to prevent this 95 idea and try
something like this but obviously this
kind of position attacking the Queen
this some young a very very difficult
for black to to play White has got
tremendous compensation for the true
pawns and he will most likely regain at
least one pawn in the near future this
is just one idea now there are others
even also in this position this kind of
move is also quite good I would say
let's say no idea for Queen here
Knight moves and now Bishop g5 I
checking the Queen it doesn't have yeah
lots of good square needs to go to f8
and also this position is obviously am
very dangerous would like to handle he's
got the King in the center
and why does got tremendous activity so
um I would say in a game between humans
is his song was unplayable but what he
did in the game was just ninety-six and
now 95 is very strong what what should
black do he doesn't have much choice he
needs to to capture the knight on d5 we
take here a check this Knight and also
I've got this this rookie one idea at
the moment the bishop prevents it but
the II farm is wide open with the Queen
and the king so this already spells
trouble yeah black 195 just took it
meant we should be to winning a tempo
again we see that right has really
brilliant position with great
development and the Kings salon can only
aid also the g7 pawn is attacked by by
the bishop so he goes to g5 still
covering this pawn and this also
explains my next move just H form trying
to distract the Queen from the g7 square
and yeah here black played queen g6 yeah
it's funny
all this has been played before you know
rather famous game between yeah Bobby
Fischer playing white and on the black
side Rubin fine who was a world-class
play in the 30s and 40s um it was long
retired by then they played this as a
friendly game in 1963 when fine was
already yeah yeah quite I would and
inactive for quite a number of years but
Fischer played the the Evans gambit
against him and this was also included
in the famous book my 60 memorable
memorable games the the fish of fine
game continued after age 4 with taking
just to show it briefly it's not not
very long Bishop takes g7 attacking the
rook so when he got got one
square now just the check on you one
fine
one here you can you can take on you
want it doesn't make much difference as
a new rocker PS King the aid and now
Queen g3 and fine resigned because of
the neat line Queen takes and shake me
and may don't have six very nice similar
stuff is also happening in the game so
in the game after age 40 didn't take it
he played the Queen to g6 and now I have
a simple but effective move Queen a3
neat little sidestep attacking the
bishop but also keeping an eye on the e7
square and yeah what should like do now
he needs to save the bishop
so he went oops
so he went Bishop to b6 yeah then I just
gave the check on e1 and yeah what
should plug do if he moves the King to
the age check me it's a maiden one and
yeah the only thing that he can do is
interpose some some pieces and lose all
of them like like Queen here and I just
take it so on why this just completely
winning and in this position even like
is beyond any and he saving him this
Queen takes edge twice the Fischer fine
game and yeah black was just blacks King
was just caught in the middle here which
is yeah in fact fairly typical of the
Evans gambit
if black grabs too much material yeah
it's a very dangerous opening and this
can also be a witness in the second game
that I played let me just um oops this
is a rotating um in the second game that
are played
um where is it just a second here oops
okay
this is this wasn't planned
okay the second game it starts out of
course with the same moves as mentioned
and the difference come cm here my palm
played Queen f6 the other move
protecting f7 and this is Sam this is
playbook very old move but playable for
instance also played by a Kasparov just
I think about two years ago in a blitz
match against Nigel short Kasparov
played to this Queen f6 move also so on
of course white just continues
development with counseling and black
not played we should be six which is
perfectly all right Kasparov played d3
in this game which is also possible
returning upon and trying to somehow
yeah slow down white White's attack but
there should be six as played in the
game as it's okay
covering this pawn yeah and I just play
d5 with the intention of opening up the
position quickly and and gaining time
and black replied Queen g6 which is also
normal Queen ozitag
you cannot really take it and to open up
the e-file this is far too risky
yeah I took on deform and in this
position I think black played played a
move that is also simply too risky
comparable to the last game he took on
deform I think this already leads to
problems for black what he should do
here
is to play Knight to e5 attacking both
both both the Queen and and the bishop
so that in this kind of position Queen a
for black get some luck at the Bishop
Pam and gets rid of this this dangerous
Bishop this was most important Knight to
e7 and in this position white is just a
pawn down he has only sacrificed one
pawn and I think still retains some
pretty a decent compensation for his
pawn
one possible continuation here which I
like is some is this move a form with
the idea to play a 5 there are the ideas
also the mediate Bishop III as a
possibility has been played by Nigel
short for instance again there are
various ideas
I like this a formal with them with this
ideas of black needs to react that react
to this in a way in general White's
plan is to go you should pay 3 maybe
next move and always attack the e7 light
and make it difficult for black to get
his King out of the center it's still a
long way until this Bishop for instance
on c8 moves or this route plays well I
just pretty quick here Bishop a
three-night somewhere and yet the roots
are connected so this is certainly a
compensation for upon the computer also
agrees it gives white full compensation
here so but this is how blacks should
play like it suddenly all right here
he's not losing it's just difficult to
play those rather defensive positions
I'd rather be white here to be honest ok
so in the game when he grabbed the
second pawn and this is as mentioned
really dangerous business okay I took
bishop takes and Knight c3 so it's a
nice leading development again
and very aggressively plays pieces the
knight on c3 also this always ready to
to jump to be 5 or d5 joining in the
tech and the general issue here so I
would like get his King out of the
center
he played 9:27 logically preparing
canceling but now this key move Bishop
to e3 and this is just one benefit of
this before move that it so opens up the
Queen side in an extent that this Bishop
very often is placed on this dangerous
diagonal preventing black from castling
it's difficult to see how black really
should yeah get out of this he played
Knight to c6 and this allows us a very
strong apply but I don't think that
black cam me had a great alternative
maybe b6 which is b6 and this move would
sure the computer suggests but this is
also not a move that young a human
player would would like to play really
it's um it looks a rather dangerous okay
but in the game he played Knight to c6
maybe under estimating the reply which
is the very strong move Knight would be
5 and here yam black has some black is
in huge trouble
yeah in the game he had declined this
this rook sacrifice and went Bishop to
b6 but we should of course look at
alternatives if black actually takes
this rook then White has a very strongly
plaza Bishop f7 and this wins instantly
between takes check and night c7 and now
why just picks up the Queen and wins
just an extra queen for for some small
change
so it
take the rook what else is there I
couldn't take any five but this is
simply punished with rook 81 and black
has absolutely no way to get out of this
alive
I just threatened f4 now winning there
at the bishop and crashing through on
the farm and if he would try to play
this white was also threatening Natick
c7 by the way then I just take f7 and
Wallace this is just just disaster
I'm simply winning a tech for just two
points then come at it wins instantly
okay so like also couldn't take a five
and so as c7 is hanging and that's not
much else he retreated to b6 and here
white has some more than one interesting
continuation an interesting alternative
for example here would have been this
move to get out of this this knight
Knight a5 idea but in the game I just
played rook a to e1 as I as I realized
that 95 is some not a huge issue still
maybe I deserve the best try I think
black the exposition really cannot be
saved anymore we should look at them in
I take five Queen a from Queen was
detect and now in this possession white
has a very strong threat the threat is
the following if black would play a move
like a six sort of okay it detects the
night but it doesn't in any way
influence the central situation then
white has the normally strong wills
ecigs and this is just wins the game
instantly black takes him check it this
double check picking up the rook so
cannot take with the D pawn
and yeah if you take with them with this
pawn then it's also a problem takes him
check and rupee six wins the Queen
yeah and it's yet YouTube future this
pin and it's still enormously strong
attack I think it's it's or even it's
close to medium it's not just the Queen
so these six is a very strong thread and
this is why black cannot play any random
move like h6 or something you can't
always go here but honestly what should
black play you cannot get the King out
of this you have the pieces out of play
well white pieces all armed you're
taking up attack the attacking positions
so I'm okay I think Knight takes e4 is
the principled idea in Quincy form and
yeah what now like really a some is in
huge trouble c7s is just saying let's
say King b8 it's just just check hmm
black mm-hmm just loses instantly as you
need to play this end after that move
from this attack is decisive
so what else let's say a six just just
to show ya white white could take but we
have an even stronger if you can you can
play Knight to d6 check and this this
wins wins instantly check yeah the
poking the you file is opened and yeah
Queen yet how would you prevent the
smooth and something like this white
goes here attacking the Queen and
attacking the bishop and this is just a
winning attack these pieces are simply
out of play
and flex precarious King position will
lose the game I think this is mated a
couple of moves most likely so this also
doesn't really help I think black cannot
be saved anymore in this position what
he did is he played the move a six and
yeah this allows and rather rather
simple finish pretty similar to the one
who saw before ninety-six check and yeah
watch what should like do now he needs
to take the light if he if he wouldn't
do it let's say yeah I can I can take
here and win the house so needs to take
the night after which I just recapture
with this check the King d8 checkmate
it's immediate made quite nice so we
need to go here and then white can Y can
simply take on v6 and this attack is
absolutely not defensible the key M
attacking movers is some rookie 7 on
light Bishop 55 trying to get rid of the
night and then have this check at the
end what quite need is something like
this if black let's say place let's say
H 5 he cannot really do anything
meaningful
then then rookie 7 just wins attacking
f7 and black is toast if you take it
need made in one so um yeah what should
what should like do that's not not much
to do in terms of defense it's just it's
just lost yeah in the game after this
night to this check on move 16 yeah
black actually resigned yeah as I'm just
shown um yeah not a minute to to only
black is really totally lost so um yeah
the Evans gambit
initiate it here with this before move I
think can be a very interesting addition
to your opening repertoire if you play
1.e4 then quite often you have to deal
with the double King pawn and of course
a principle move and maybe the main move
this is rule apes' but the Italian game
can be a nice alternative especially
considering that you can so nicely mix
somewhat slower approaches for example
after Bishop c5 you can of course also
play this the slow continuation leading
to a lengthy maneuvering game very
similar to the rule but you also have
this nice alternative with before
playing in gambit star so it's very
nicely possible to mix aggressive play
and slower more positional satirical
play in the Italian game don't think it
can be recommended especially if you
face opponents where you have the
suspicion that they don't know the
theory too well man the Evans can be
really deadly yeah I hope you like the
two quick attacking wins and yeah make
sure to check out this opening if you
play 1.e4 I think it's worth it yeah
thanks and bye